a lot Oh everyone welcome to today's
live broadcast news specificities in the
antiphospholipid syndrome the importance
of testing for a PS PT and anti beta to
domain one antibodies
I am Brenda Kelly Kim of lappers and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth and sponsored by ANOVA
Diagnostics ANOVA Diagnostics is a
privately held company headquartered in
San Diego California the company was
founded in 1987 and has over 360 team
members around the world we are leaders
in the development and commercialization
of new autoimmune technology and
diagnostic markers for more than 25
years the Innova Diagnostics team has
collaborated with clinical researchers
to develop biomarkers that help advance
the care of autoimmune disease patients
we are redefining autoimmunity
leveraging our innovative spirit to
deliver solutions that anticipate the
needs of the laboratory and improve
efficiency and quality of testing for
more information please visit
www.carmensognonvi.com/newsletter by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide leader
and if you have any technical problems
hearing or viewing this presentation
properly please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problems for the green Q&A button lower
left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. maria lara bertha
cheney was born in Rosario Argentina
where she graduated from the medical
school at the National University of
Rosario she joined the lupus unit in
1996 as a clinical research fellow in
2004 she was awarded her PhD degree by
King's College London doctor bertolucci
knees and
managing editor of Lucas and
International Journal she's the co-chair
of the standardization subcommittee on
lupus anticoagulant and antiphospholipid
antibodies at the International Society
for thrombosis and hemostasis chairman
of the antiphospholipid syndrome
laboratory Diagnostics and trends task
force an executive committee member of
the antiphospholipid syndrome Alliance
for clinical trials and international
networking ApS action dr. Bertoli cheney
has published 84 peer-reviewed papers
two books 11 chapters and presented more
than 85 abstracts at national and
international meetings will now turn you
over to Laura for her presentation so
thank you very much in the next few
minutes I'm going to present you all the
data available on the importance of
testing for anti phosphatidylserine
proton beam and anti beta to the main
one antibodies so we all know that in
the clinical setting the most tested
antibodies are dose directed to
cardiolipin
aunt Anita - and the Lucas anticoagulant
but although these tests are the best
available and they are clinically useful
in the majority of the cases they do not
recognize the wide range of
specificities for the antiphospholipid
syndrome so there is a constant search
for new specificities most of the
studies had been focused on anti Dita -
like a protein one due to the fact that
they have been shown to be more specific
than Antica Villepin antibodies and
these have been shown since very very
early studies as you can see in this
slide so beta 2 lipoprotein 1 is the
natural anticoagulant and we all know
that is an essential requirement to
differentiate pathogenic from not
non-pathogenic anti cardiolipin
antibodies
Peter - like Oh protein 1 is composed by
five domains with the domain 5
responsible for the binding to
forcefully
under main one that is exposed when the
molecule it suffers a conformation and
change so in the search for the episodes
of aunt Anita two glycoprotein one
antibodies antibodies to all the domains
of the Vita to have been reported
however most of the studies showed that
this epitope was located in domain one
and therefore their pension was focused
on this part of the molecule
early studies from 2005 from the group
by the lab showed that there were two
types of antedated - like Oh protein 1
antibodies those that recognized domain
one that were responsible for lupus and
equivalent activity and we are highly
associated with reverses and another
group with a thorough genius reactivity
for all the domains several studies have
been published in the literature
referring to the clinical significance
of testing for anti domain 1 antibodies
but one of the most important papers was
published back in 2009 were the group of
the lab again so that anti domain 1 was
present in 55 percent of the patients
positive for anti beta 2 lipoprotein 1
antibodies 83 percent had rhombuses and
they were also associated with pregnancy
morbidity in a recent study from the
group of Professor Pengo by using a
deletion assays they show that
antibodies to domain one were more
frequently present in those patients
with triple positivity for
antiphospholipid antibodies
a recent study also from the group of
andreoli at all they try to pit to
characterize clinically antiphospholipid
a directed - River - lipoprotein one and
they have shown as you can see in the
the scream that from all the group of
anti beta 2 glycoprotein 1 in the figure
of the center representing the domain 1
and in the figure of the right those
antibodies directed to domain 4 and 5 so
they show that most of the antibodies
directed to Rita to glycoprotein 1 were
adapted in reality to a anti domain 1
what is more important from antibodies
directed to the main one is that these
antibodies are pathogenic when infused
into a mouse in a mouse model of
thrombosis as you can see on the left of
this slide a animals injected with an T
domain 1 show a higher thrombosis and
improvised a higher tissue factor
activity in the carotid artery
endothelium in a recent study from our
group we also showed that these
antibodies can be helpful in
discriminating patients with the so
called seronegative antiphospholipid
syndrome we show that 7.5 percent of the
patients who were negative for all
antiphospholipid a profile but we're
having a clinical features of the
antiphospholipid syndrome were also
found to be positive for antibodies an T
domain 1 o programming is another target
important for antiphospholipid
antibodies as we all know press from
beneath a plasma protein that circulates
in plasma at the concentration of 2.5
micromolar Rita prothrombin is activated
by the proton Benes complex into
something that in turn activates protein
c and protein s starting the fear
analytic pathway an analogy with the
antibodies to Rita to glycoprotein 1 has
been also described for antiproton beam
antibodies
Rondon should be exposed to a particular
surface to suffer a conformational
change and expose a epitope that are
detected by antiphospholipid antibodies
they are two ways of detecting these
antibodies one is coating press rounding
on to an irradiated play that will give
the negative a surface and another is by
coating proton beam over a
phosphatidylserine layer also providing
a negative layer that will allow the
epitope expression so our earlier
studies in 2005 showed that anti
prothrombin on the left and anti
phosphatidylserine proton beam on the
right
wear a associated with from bosses these
antibodies were not only more frequently
found in patients with from both East
and in those without but also treat
eaters were higher so our first question
was that find they are two ways of
detecting the same antibodies but when
we try to correlate them with five we
failed although you can see in this
slide that many patients had both
antibodies
there were many discreet discrepancies
with some patients present in one
antibody and others present in the other
so what is more interesting from these
antibodies is that none of these
antibodies interfere with the from beam
antigen level in plasma nor with proton
beam antigen activity suggesting that
these antibodies do not affect the
function of programming in plasma so
what do we know about epitope Ferranti
prothrombin antibodies well we do not
know a lot about this the epitopes are
not known they may be at our genius and
they could be binding to any part of the
molecule our very preliminary data show
that antibodies to phosphor
Sharon prothrombin are unable to
recognize fragment 1 in solid phase this
could be due to two factors one that the
epital is not located in fragment 1 or 2
that the antibodies meet the presence of
the whole molecule of prothrombin to
recognize the epitope that may be
covered so we have two different
antibodies a TT and a pspp that have
been shown to have a different
immunological characteristics we don't
know much about the episode but what do
we know about the clinical significance
so we decided to undergo a systematic
review of the literature in a search to
find what was reported without regarding
dis antibodies as you can see in this
slide when we analyze the studies
available on antithrombin prothrombin
coated in solid phase we found a wide
range of results with some studies
showing association between the presence
of these antibodies and from bosses and
others failing to confirm this
association when we analyzed the data
available for anti phosphatidylserine
surrounding the association to
thrombosis was clear with almost all but
one of the studies showing a significant
association that was stronger for venous
thrombosis as you can see in the graph
on the right another important question
is the association between these
antibodies and the lupus anticoagulant
activity they have been very early
reports in a patient with iPoker from
bulimia that presented until recently
presented and a prolongation of the
correlation test later on in 1991 V
versatile suggested that antibodies to
prasanan could be a cofactor for the
Lupus NT : tactility
the group from professor at SUNY showed
that from all their patients a PSP d+
95% shown to be were shown to read Lucas
and equivalent positive suggesting that
ap SBT may serve as one of the
confirmatory test for lupus
anticoagulant so we decided to analyze
this theory and we studied a group of a
group of patients with and without lupus
anticoagulant while we shown that
patients with lupus anticoagulant had
more frequently anti prothrombin and
anti phosphatidyl for entry from the
antibodies we also were able to
demonstrate that anti phosphatidylserine
safranin were independent of the
presence of lupus anticoagulant and were
independent risk factors for thrombosis
so we have lots of antibodies most of
them being under research so we try to
determine what was the a diagnostic
precision or the accuracy for diagnosis
finding a profile that would help us in
this task so we evaluated 23 possible
combinations of antiphospholipid
antibodies this slide is just to show
you some of the combinations that we use
in a search for which profile would help
us in better identify in the end
phospholipid syndrome so the diagnostic
accuracy was best when we use the
combination of testing for lupus
anticoagulant anti dita - glycoprotein 1
and anti phosphatidylserine present in
this diagnostic accuracy was not only a
best for antiphospholipid syndrome as a
whole but also when we searched for some
bosses and pregnancy loss independently
surprisingly this diagnostic accuracy
was even better than that that we could
see by using they a current a
classification
laboratory criteria a lupus
anticoagulant and psyckadeli been an
antibiotic like a protein one what is
more important is that we were also able
to demonstrate that each of these
antibodies was a thrombotic risk factor
or an independent robotic risk factor
and the addition of an antibody to
another one would increase the risk with
the presence of an TD tattoo anti
phosphatidylserine program beam and
lupus anticoagulant increasing this risk
23 it falls so how do we measure risk
this is one of the big questions that we
have in the clinic so in an attempt to
define risk or trying to stratify
patients according to risk we decide
that global antiphospholipid syndrome
score so this risk or was derived from
the combination of several independent
risk factors being anti phosphatidyl
transfer from being one of the risk
factors found to be independent so what
what did we see I apply in this score we
saw in a population of lupus that this
score was able to discriminate patients
with drum bosses from those without we
saw in a population of primary
antiphospholipid syndrome that this
score would discriminate patients with
thrombosis from those without rhombuses
and what was more important it was able
to discriminate those patients with
recurrences from those without we also
applied this global antiphospholipid
syndrome for in a prospective cause of
patients with antiphospholipid syndrome
and we show that an increase of 3 points
in the score during follow-up was a risk
factor for thrombotic events the
percentage of time free from a traumatic
event
was lower and statistically lower in
patients who didn't have an increase in
the gap during the follow-up what is
more important are these ApS PT
pathogenic well the group of professor
at suny again showed that
phosphatidylserine dependent antiproton
beam antibodies induced tissue factor
expression on propellant cells in vitro
and this effect is produced via a p38
MAP kinase pathway in our laboratory we
have shown in another animal model of
inferior vena cava literature that
animals in fields with anti phosphatidyl
transfer from beam induce or have a
higher a bigger thrombus and a heavier
thrombus unfortunately this paste is
under embargo and therefore I cannot
present it today but is a very
interesting and confirm the pathogenic
effect of anti phosphatidylserine
quarantine so in conclusion regarding
anti-roman one antibodies we show that
cross-sectional and retrospective data
show that an T domain one positivity is
associated with some bosses and
pregnancy morbidity of course
importantly animal models show
pathogenicity of fanta domain one
antibodies whether the frequency of
patients positive for NT domain one and
negative for interior to still not
establish and definitely deserves more
research and the value of an T domain
one as the sole antibody is still to be
determined without in anti-fatigue is
Franco from beam we know that aunty for
status around the thrombin but not anti
prefer indeed in solid phase are
independent risk factors for thrombosis
are independent from the presence of
lupus anticoagulant and along with lupus
anticoagulant and an talita to
lipoprotein one antibodies this ApS PT
can offer the best diagnostic accuracy
for
es thrombosis and pregnancy
complications so we believe that by
including a PS pts laboratory criteria
for ATS we may achieve a better
diagnostic performance an unimproved
robotic risk assessment the most
important message I would like to leave
with you today is that the clinical view
on antiphospholipid antibodies has
entirely changed and the value of
antiphospholipid antibodies have evolved
from being markers of disease to be
important independent risk factors for
thrombosis the risk is associated to
that presence and it seems that is not
to the level of the antibodies and
therefore these patients presenting
antibodies should be closely monitored
thank you very much
thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question-and-answer session I would
like to remind our audience how to
submit their questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to get to
as many of your questions as we can and
we do have a first question coming in
from our audience the question is there
any lab in the u.s. currently offering
the domain one test well my
understanding is that there is a lab in
Oakland California Meishan labs are
offering this test at the moment great
that's good to know
our next question at this time how would
you recommend using domain 1 in a
clinical setting would you recommend
testing triple positive patients or
domain one well I think it is clear that
once you have the diagnosis you need to
test more antibodies so I would and I
probably not recommend testing in
addition to the other antibodies however
these antibodies may be helpful if you
have a patient with a clinical features
that has been shown to be negative for
all the currently use antibodies and
perhaps testing for domain one and a PSP
T may help in identifying the
antiphospholipid syndrome great thank
you
our next question how would you treat
domain one positive patients versus
patients who are domain one negative
would you alter the course of therapy
well probably not and I don't know I
think you do not treat antibodies but
you treat the disease so once you have
the diagnosis you need to treat
accordingly the antibodies are tools
that should be put into their clinical
setting so the clinical manifestation
so no probably I would not change the
course of treatment at the moment but
yes I would test for these antibodies to
help in the diagnosis thank you give
another question it sounds like the
evidence for PSP T is strong would be
included as a classification criteria
test in the near future
well evidence for a PSP T is really
strong and what is more important there
is a sort of a stable data coming out in
from different groups which make it
stronger so inclusion of a PSP T as part
of the laboratory criteria will be
discussed in Istanbul in the next and
phospholipid meeting so we will see stay
tuned
great bring forward to that Eve another
question our commercial assay is
available for domain one auto antibodies
well if there is a commercial si
available from Innova for a domain one
out two antibodies yes thank you for the
answer I think we do still have some
more questions coming in if we do can
you have can you test for a PSP T while
the patient is on anticoagulation
therapy yes you can as we show in the
slides before a antibodies do not
interfere with performing and there
shouldn't be any alteration of the
antibody during anticoagulation so yes
you can test them right / - no our next
question once
APF is diagnosed is there any purpose to
remeasuring APL Auto antibodies what is
the effect of an APL Auto lab on the
fetus excluding spontaneous abortion
well we use at least at
intimacies they use a retesting of a TL
maybe once a year it's just a case of
monitoring rather from diagnosis once
the patient is diagnosed the diagnosis
is clear so usually a patients are
treated accordingly and even if they
become negative there is a little bit of
controversies they can be put out of
treatment or not there are no clinical
trials that show that this patients are
at less risk so you remain sure
antiphospholipid antibodies a sort of
monitoring but even if the antibodies
become negative most of the groups are
still treating these patients once they
have the diagnosis regarding the effect
of antiphospholipid in the fetus
excluding spontaneous abortion well
there is a lot of data I imagine so
antiphospholipid antibodies have been
related to early miscarriages to fetal
death to preeclampsia to placental
insufficiency and recent data from
Professor Girardi is showing that
antiphospholipid antibodies may cross
the blood-brain barrier in the fetus and
probably this will be a long-term effect
of APL in the babies so this is data
that she is working on and hopefully we
will have some answers to this in the
near future
great thank you we're getting lots of
good input and questions from our
audience I just want to encourage our
audience that this is the time to ask
any questions of war and for
presentation today clicking on the green
Q&A button bring those questions right
to us we would love to hear from you
with those questions
okay Laura do you have any other
comments for our audience while we're
waiting for couple questions
no I think that is a lot of of work to
be done on and phospholipid antibodies a
an T domain one are a very important and
a very hot a target for antiphospholipid
antibodies and a lot of data on anti
domain one will be presented in Istanbul
as well and regarding ATS BT we believe
that they are risk factors associated
with thrombosis and hopefully this
marker will be included in the
laboratory criteria soon great concern
like a very exciting area of research
with lots of information coming soon we
do have another question from our
audience do domain one Auto labs differ
so you can do it like that one yes do
auto domain one Auto labs differ when
being presented I'm sorry I can't see
the question do autumn do domain one
Auto labs differ whether or not the
patient has SLE a silly no a 30% of
patients with the lupus haven't
phospholipid antibodies so many of the
studies on domain one and a PSP have
been performed in patients with lupus
and now there is an agreement that Lucas
and ApS has two different conditions so
even if domain one can be presented in a
patient with SLE the antibodies are
similar and behave in a similar way
great
thank you for that I don't see any more
questions in our queue from our audience
I do at this point
want to let Laura wrap up our
presentation any final comments or
advice that she has for our audience we
do have a question I'm sorry
is there an importance of IgM antibodies
of pspp where IBM antibodies to pspp
have been highly associated with the
lupus anticoagulant so we are trying to
investigate further
if this association is because they
share some sort of function or if they
are independently associated but IgM ATS
PT has been highly correlated with the
presence of anticoagulant great thanks
for that I do want to also thank our
sponsor today and over diagnostics for
making today's educational webcast
possible as well as dr. Bartlett Cheney
for taking her time today to explain
this area of research to us today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through May 2016 you'll receive
an email from laggards alerting you when
this webcast will be available for
replay and we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live oven thank you
attended dr. fertile the Cheney and Nova
Diagnostics for this webcast hope to see
you again next time okay